Justin's with us in Colorado hi Justin
how are you good Dave how are you
better than I deserve how can I help yes
so I'm kind of piggybacking off the
student loans that's why I'm calling
so collectively um first of all one of
my best friends Tyler introduced me to
you guys and it's been we've been on
we've been 100% on Dave for about three
months now and we were able to wipe out
all of our credit cards which is about
1,800 in debt um so yeah the biggest
reason why we're asking is I'm actually
getting ready to relocate from Colorado
out to Chattanooga
in which real estate is about half the
price as it is out here so I got a
$20,000 a year raised plus we're gonna
be saving almost 900 a months in rent so
we'll be able to really kind of add
toward the snowball so collectively me
and my wife are four hundred and sixty
thousand in debt in which four hundred
and thirty five thousand of it is
student loans
this is the doctor who's the lawyer I am
okay I am I'm a chiropractor you're a
high yes you pay for chiropractic school
chiropractic school was probably pretty
close to with grad plus probably 350 and
how many chiropractors make enough to
justify anywhere near that none maybe 1%
like the upper 1% yeah that's probably
true okay so with your $20,000 raise
what are you gonna be making
Moby's with the raise and once bonus
because we get her adjustment bonuses
and stuff like that I'll be roughly
between it's gonna fluctuate between a
hundred and about 115 for now here as I
help and then what about your wife what
does she do um we have well she is a
cancer survivor so November of last year
she was diagnosed with stage 3 small
intestinal cancer so we have three kids
and she's actually cooking number four
so right now with us being in Colorado
it was what
jeepers for her to leave her job to take
care of the kids full-time instead of
paying almost 1,800 a weekend childcare
okay so we have a four hundred and fifty
thousand dollar problem with $100,000
income in four kids in Chattanooga
Tennessee it's going alone yeah don't
take a while yeah if we get you know
just
rough numbers if you did fifty thousand
dollars a year and lived on 50 that's
ten years still yes yep so that's kind
of a question right because we can get
into a very modest single-family home
for the family for probably between 2
and 250 issues dollars in debt you don't
need to be buying a house you need to
rent as cheaply as you can and really
fight and struggle and scratch with your
income and as your kids age and get
towards school mama probably needs to be
up her career again or this households
in desperate need of income not expenses
okay and right now what I see for you is
a long slog the number of chiropractors
that make 200 a year is as you said it's
very small but you need to be one of
them
because the number of contractors that
go 350 in debt to be a chiropractor is
really low - most of them are more like
150 to 200 and even then it's not worth
it but yep I uh for the benefit not of
you calling I mean for you calling you
got a long slog I'll walk with you
we're gonna be friends for a long time
and you're gonna get through this and
you're gonna fight to get your income up
for the benefit of a young person out
there listening would you agree with me
that that $350,000 in debt is not worth
it for $110,000 job
hello yeah I oh no I wouldn't I would
agree with you a hundred percent okay
okay
I just um I don't want to put words in
your mouth and I didn't want to trash
you because you're there you know and I
want to walk with you and help you I'm
not here to shame you that's not my
point but on you know I'd like to catch
you before you did this and you're in
that version of you is out there
listening right now and thinking about
going to chiropractic school and the
return on investment it's it's not an MD
you know it's not an MD in terms of
income production we can have a
discussion about the philosophy of
medicine we can have a discussion about
the treatments that are provided versus
the other treatments that are provided
traditional medicine versus other kinds
of medicine we can have all those
philosophical and legitimate discussions
but ROI there's no planet in which you
spend three hundred fifty thousand
dollars folks to be a chiropractor so
and then have four kids so and Mama's
not working and as a cancer survivor
so you guys got a you know you're just
gonna have to be very austere for a
while and you'll begin to make progress
and you'll push your way through it and
again we'll be here with you we're gonna
help you I'm not not saying it's
hopeless I'm just saying to anybody else
that are considering it take a lesson
from him that this is not a path you
want to do that was fairly gentle
apparently